we make way I believe for Mark Wahlberg
yes Paulie Mark has a new movie comes
out on Friday it's daddy's home to in
theaters everywhere on Friday and Mark
joins us we had Will Ferrell on
yesterday mark and I think you might be
rubbing off on him because he's in too
good of shape here but he Jack man he's
doing good I had him I hadn't seen him
since we finished the movie actually I
saw him once we always screened the
movie but he looked really good now I
did ask him if you know you get in too
good a shape maybe you're not as funny
you know like we like will little fatter
so we're concerned about this mark I
understand the concerns and thankfully
we're not shooting another movie for a
while so I think he'll be back to his
regular form when I see him underwear
and all is there any nudity in this
movie a woman's housecoat which is a
very small one okay good in it have you
tried Tom Brady's workout regimen all
the things he eats don't know would you
know needs to do for Tom and I need to
do what I need to do for me you know I
think Tom you know he's a tall slender
man you know I'm usually trying to build
some month put some put on some muscle
or you know depending on what I have to
do to prepare for roles but uh no I
think cosmetic secrets maybe I would
follow some of Tom's tips he's such a
good-looking gentleman but as far as no
not working out I've got to do my own
thing
would you take a role where you added 30
like you let yourself go a little bit
I've done it I actually did it quite a
few times I've done it actually three
times for Pete Berg but one time I
wasn't in that bad of shape for lone
survivor but I had just on pain and gain
where I went up to 212 and I was all
month but but then I
two guns in between that and then I were
right into lone survivor but then with
Patriots Day and Deepwater Horizon he
wanted me to put it on as much weight as
possible for both of those movies so
Depot on her rise and I spent three and
a half months in Louisiana just eating
fried food and drinking a lot we're
talking to Mark Wahlberg the movie is
daddy's home to in theaters Friday this
Friday coming up November 10th what
about this movie why is sequel with this
when did you decide and why you know
well and I we had so much fun making the
first movie and you know people really
love that I would seems a big hit but
then the writers and director Sean Sean
Anders and John Morris they came up with
a great idea that could kind of really
make it its own unique thing and
introducing the dads and kind of going
on this whole other journey and so once
we heard the idea we thought it was
worth doing because we figured we could
make it better than the first which is
the only real reason to do a sequel
unless you know you just want a paycheck
but you know there's other paychecks to
be had out there and I don't want to go
messing up a movie that's beloved by
audience but these guys really really
spent the time doing the work developing
and writing the script so they did a
great job are your kids a good target
audience will they be honest with you
when they see one of your movies oh my
kids are brutally honest they're
actually they're they're harsh I like to
beat that down a little bit
do they think you're cool I know what
your daughter thinks but does the house
the rescue
I would I would like for somebody to be
able to ask them like away from me what
they really think but I don't think
they'd take them cool I think they think
I'm pretty annoying but if I could get
them hooked up with something or someone
that they wanted me or someone they'd
want to know that I'm probably cool for
a very small portion of time but when
you rapped last time you were here with
your daughter
now we loved it but I want to know what
it was like when you left because I
didn't know if you two were on the same
page you know she was annoyed by it but
she had such a good time being there and
being on the show and she actually was
up
that when I told her I was gonna be back
on the show and she wasn't gonna be with
me I like that she was like she feels
like it's her thing you know
well I'm time there I go without I'm
trying to get her in studio just so you
know we're not gonna have we're trying
to bypass you and just have your
daughter in absolutely as soon as you
get some grades up I'll flower right
what else you got on the agenda here I
just worked P nine people are actually
gonna do a movie starting in November
we're doing a character-driven action
movie that's not based on real events
so I actually I'm getting in really good
shape for Pete but now it's like he's
getting annoyed that I'm in really good
shape so he's like well after the first
week of shooting we'll have dinners and
wine and I'm like well Pete I stopped
drinking wine so I could get in shape
with you you said you wanted to finally
have me in shape because I'd never been
shaping a movie but now he's like to
listen you know thank me like he's
running around with the shirt off so we
can we can drink some on it like so why
you just happy you know start training
three months ago and now not drinking
anything or eating really clean for 30
days just to torture me what if your
kids don't like Boston sports teams do
any of your kids like somebody else my
youngest son loved the Knicks and he
liked the Yankees and you know what I to
see him wearing an a-rod Jersey in my
backyard and also you know wearing a
Carmelo shirt it took a little bit but
you know that's my guy whatever he likes
I'm with them and I actually I'll root
for the Knicks I'm not so quick to root
for the Yankees but I'll root for the
Knicks for him and he you know with this
first in the mural basketball team
playing for the Knicks of then he just
adopted everything New York except for
footballs a die-hard Patriots fan which
is which is more than enough for me that
would be crossing the line anything else
is okay what did you think when
Garoppolo got traded
I understood you know you don't want to
all of a sudden next year and being uh
you know franchise tag and make it more
than Tom but I also feel a little bad
form because it's gonna get thrust into
the the mix of San Francisco and you
know I don't think you'll have that good
of a chance to succeed there
well it'd be interesting to see what
happens within there would you go to a
Yankee game with your son at Yankee
Stadium yes absolutely
you begrudgingly you would go I would go
yeah I would love to actually go I'd sit
in the judges section the judge's
chambers I want to see our errant judge
hit one of those moon-rocket home runs I
like that I like now that's that's a guy
who's jacked I don't know if he would be
is he too big to be an actor like too
tall I know the rock is pretty
good-sized but Judge at six seven like
is there a certain height that you just
you can't be a great actor oh he might
be a little too big no maybe maybe him
in Gronk in a movie together have you
cast brunella for uh he well he's been
an entourage and stuff like that yeah
but he's you know he's off doing his own
thing he does a lot of stuff we had
Edelman in last week you you might have
you might oh man he was great he's full
full bro he's first-team all bro
absolutely you know when I reached out
to my overseas you know just letting
know that I was thinking about him I
felt bad and he was like you know it's
all good man I'll be back next year I'm
gonna be stronger and then you know he's
really happy my son where's number 11
playing tackle football for the LA City
doctor nan Orrock Union so you know
Julian always sends a message is about
wearing the sticks and you know the
pride that goes along with wearing
number 11 I know I just hoping he's get
back soon but did you hear what Brady
text him when he got hurt he said have
family have a scoop of cement and get
back you gotta use that in the movie
tell Berg you want to put that in in
this script here a scoop of cement and
it has a tribute to Brady I tell you
what I think he would try to if he could
he would I like that a little good luck
with the movie great to talk to you
thanks for making some time and we'll
talk to you down the road thank you Dan
appreciates buddy for more dance
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]